[Music]
chuck we got another explainer video
ready to drop
ah yes and a good one indeed
well i don't know if it's good yet well
you know what
i do i do indeed
you're thinking this one's going to be
good i i'm telling you right now because
we we got we got some really um
some significant help to make this one
really good and i love
getting some help we've got james green
from nasa
with us to do an explainer video on mars
mars because we are going back to mars
jim great to have you back remind me of
your like full title at nasa uh i am the
nasa chief scientist excuse me
exactly i i was the head of planetary
that's what i thought that's what i
remembered yeah no i
i uh got promoted uh-huh so that's
nice so jim you got that new fancy title
okay but also you got into the
podcast business okay what's the name of
your podcast
it's called gravity assist this is our
game yeah yeah
it's the fourth season and uh today
uh we've been taping uh all about the
search for life
beyond earth it's a great season
excellent
excellent so we just launched the mars
perseverance rover
why didn't we launch last year or oh
well you know
indeed every 26 months the orbits of
earth and mars line up to be on the same
side of the sun
that we actually can get to mars as
quickly as possible so it's a window
it's a window yeah yeah and so it's much
like american football where you throw
the football
down the field and the receiver runs and
grabs it
and that's all that's what we're going
to do it's a ballistic trajectory from
earth to mars
so so you're launching this to arrive
where mars will be when it gets there
on the 18th of february mark my word
wow my boy's got some confidence in
newtonian physics right
i was going to say he better uh seeing
how uh i saw the budget
so helped us out you know
so so jim what's uh what's different
about this rover compared to the others
uh this one is absolutely fantastic
it's a huge step forward because not
only does it
sort of look like curiosity it's got all
new instruments
and one of them on the arm is
a rock corer so we are going to mars
and creating cores like this
so it's not just it's not just the
surface
material right you're going in we're
going in
we're going to core rock and rock
the rock record is so important as we
know here on earth it's the
history of the geology of the earth same
thing on mars
so we're going to look for aspects of
climate change
and whether early mars may have had life
so where are you targeting on mars for
this we're going to a crater
called jezreel crater but it's really
it's really right at the ancient
shoreline of mars
and so there's a river an ancient river
bringing material from
large regions on mars into this crater
and depositing a delta and then flowing
over the crater wall
into the ancient ocean jim there's no
water
on mars now so not at the moment but in
the past
in the past in the past now it turns out
mars
does have an enormous amount of water
it's just locked underneath the
surface and in the in the northern polar
cap
but what you're describing as this
target is
a place where formerly water was just
there
right four billion years ago and you're
you're going for beachfront property
yeah and you know why it's really you
know we think about life coming
out of our ocean onto land learning how
to evolve and live on the land
and so the the you know that ancient
shoreline
is where a lot of our missions go gotcha
so now where is the atmospheric
generator buried deep inside of mars
where would that be
[Laughter]
chuck wants to move there chuck wants to
buy property on that beachfront
wants a condo hey listen you know what
they say buy on the fringe
and wait okay you may have to ask arnold
about where he'd find it there
arnold exactly
send you back to mars
[Music]
[Laughter]
so uh if this is styled like uh
curiosity was
does that mean it will arrive at mars
the same way curiosity did
and what was that there was six minutes
of terror will it survive
the the entry are we gonna watch we're
gonna experience that again with this
we are we're gonna use the same process
if it worked once
and you know it's not always a guarantee
it's gonna work exactly the same way
we're going to do that again
and the reason why is this rover is even
more massive than curiosity is
this one is a little more than one
metric ton
wow so you're talking about can i ask
you both a question
it's the size of a car you're dropping a
car that's huge
so can i ask you guys a question when
you talk about you know dropping this
rover down
into mars okay so when
something enters earth's atmosphere it's
basically the
atmosphere that is the problem because
it's a lot of friction
creates all this heat but mars doesn't
have a lot of atmosphere
right so what are the big worries and
what's the big like uh drawback to
putting something on the surface of mars
wait chuck i have to correct you just
briefly you're thinking of the
atmosphere as a problem because
it's heat it's not however go ahead the
atmosphere
allows you to slow down oh so atmosphere
is breaks
out yes yes okay jim take it from there
all right so when we hit the top of the
atmosphere we're going 13
000 miles per hour and when we land
six and a half minutes later we've got
to be going inches per second
wow and so we have a lot of momentum to
take out
and it starts with the heat shield okay
and one way to do that
is uh mars's atmosphere is actually much
thinner than ours
and so we need to travel in the
atmosphere as much as we can
so we change the center of gravity of
the capsule
instead of having it come down straight
we blow some mass
[ __ ] it this way and fly as parallel
to the surface of mars as we can so
with without even without even having
atmosphere you're almost creating like a
glider
well the friction indeed just slows it
down
from that 13 000 miles per hour to then
about 250 or so miles per hour
then we change the mass distribution
write it
papa shoot and that shoot then
allows us to get it down below 100 miles
an hour or so
before we drop the rover to the surface
okay now i'm just going to say something
i've never been in a uh
i've never been in a collision at 100
miles an hour before
uh because i probably wouldn't be here
so correct
so i mean you you say that like a
hundred miles an hour as a fender bender
how do you what happens what happens at
100 miles an hour when you hit the
ground
well we have a platform that sits on top
of the rover
and it has retro rockets they then take
off
and slow the vehicle down
from 100 miles an hour from 100 miles an
hour yeah from 100 miles an hour
slows it down and actually stops it
at about 25 meters from the surface
which chuck just to be clear they could
have done that
upon contact with the atmosphere but it
would have needed fuel
to slow them down from 13 000 miles an
hour so why not use
the atmosphere to take most of that out
and save the little bit of fuel you're
carrying for just that last little leg
did i get that right yeah that's right
and so what will happen then
this uh this uh platform that sits on
top of the rover is called the sky crane
and the reason why is we're going to
crane it down to the surface
so as we start the craning then the then
the fact that we've sort of folded up
the rover
inside and tucked it into the capsule
allows it
for the wheels to come out and lock and
everything get ready for then
the rover to sit down on the surface
at inches per second so you've got a
joist that's unrolling for this thing to
descend
yeah that's crazy no it's not
it makes fantastic sense when you think
about it but there's a lot of thing it's
like a rube goldberg thing
first you do you do the hokey pokey you
move the center of mass
you put out the drug shoot you have the
retro rockets
you pop the tires and i'm thinking
aren't those many points oh yeah
that's right and we have to test each
and every one of them and then we try to
figure out how to test them in between
but because curiosity landed using that
same
approach we have great confidence that
we can re
repeat that okay so we'll use the same
procedures
what are these images i've seen of
something that looks like it it's got
like
uh drone propellers or something what is
that
ah so in addition to the rover you know
that
that looks like curiosity you know this
huge rover this little model of it
underneath the belly pan sits what we
call
a technology demonstration mission
and it turns out to be a helicopter and
it's a counter rotating
uh set of uh uh of
wings you know that then uh rotate
blades that rotate more than 3000 rpm
and then uh takes off now how we do that
is we first drop it then we get out of
the way
and then we send the command take off
that's super cool and then
is is it going anywhere or is it to go
take pictures
is it yeah because it's a test you know
we've never
flown anything in in an atmosphere
besides the earth so this is the first
flight of an object and you need those
high rpms because of the thin atmosphere
right that's right and it's only four
pounds
so it's only lifting a little box about
four
pounds and so it's going to go through
several tests so the first test is
pick up go a couple meters up and then
come down
that and that'll be successful then
we'll charge up the batteries and the
next day we'll do another test that test
will be
go up translate and then sit down
translate it's code for move sideways
move sideways yes okay sorry
right i thought it was just going to
like start to learn martian you know
translated tomorrow translate hello
we come in peace so
so jim this mission is um
you you speak of it as though you're
just having a conversation with the
rover
but there's the time delay of your
signal it's like what 20 minutes 10
20 minutes or so well for mars is orbit
based on where earth is it can be
anywhere from four minutes to 22 minutes
okay so you can't just say watch out for
the cliff right
and it's too late that's right and so
what's happening now
is uh we will be about uh six or seven
minutes away
uh light travel time to uh to mars
and so everything's got to be done
automatically
the whole entire landing sequence is
done automatically
all right so so james your your
professional background is it from
geology or from astronomy
i'm a magnetospheric physicist okay well
neither
okay yeah so so i never met a magnetic
field i didn't like
wow okay so um so tell me what
experiments are on this mission and then
we got to sort of wrap it up after that
so ranking in your favorite order of
what this thing is going to do
all right so the core that's important
there's two instruments that help the
core make the decision once
by the way i'm not a geologist i keep
thinking what the rock is on the surface
is probably the same a few inches in but
you're telling me no the rock could be
completely different on the inside
curiosity told us that so when you know
the the red mars is there and when we
took uh and dug just below the surface
we saw gray mars
oh because it's not oxidized it's a
planet it's not oxidized
oh it's a different planet
mars is red from the iron oxides okay
got it right
so indeed finding the right spot to core
is important
and so the context instruments are
sherlock and pixel those are on the arm
and they're going to do imaging and
they're going to help us decide here's
where we're going to go
in addition to that we have another
instrument called rimfax it's from
norway and it sits
underneath the belly pan next to where
the copter would be
after we drop it and it is a ground
penetrating radar it gives a
stratigraphy
it gives us an idea hey this might be a
good place to drill
that's important and then we have you
know
right on the mast uh right here at the
top
a fabulous instrument uh uh
called super camp and it is designed to
send out a laser evaporate the rock get
a spectrum
and help us understand the composition
of the rocks in front of us and then
guide us to where
we want to go you know chuck chuck if if
if martians
are there on the surface and they see
this with laser beams coming out of it
they're going to think we're declaring
war exactly we no longer come in peace
we no longer come in peace we come here
to vaporize you exactly you know
you know they may think we're just
heating up the place so they can you
know barbecue out but that might be a
different story
another instrument is mass cam all right
and this one you know has um has a
fabulous set of cameras that sit below
super cam and and they are at about
the height of my eyes which uh since i'm
six four
at about six feet so the stereo imaging
we get is going to be just like a human
walking around on the surface
so then we have an instrument called
moxie this is the one that brings in the
atmosphere
we zap it and so you take co2 which is a
predominant
atmospheric composition pop off an
oxygen
giving you then carbon monoxide and
oxygen you vent the carbon monoxide
and then you understand how much oxygen
you can get from the process
and we do that during the morning
afternoon and evening and throughout the
year
that gives us an efficiency factor and
that's you know that's like
mark watney's oxygenator this is so this
is like if you if you go there this
you'll have prior knowledge of how
effectively you can
pull oxygen out of the co2 molecule
that's right
and and that's important to supplement
whatever we take there and in fact it
may be
the main way we acquire oxygen to use in
a variety of purposes
breathing of course is one of them
adding hydrogen to it gives us water
so there's you know oxygen is important
got to have it
there's another instrument that is
pretty special to me
all right and and hardly anyone knows
about it
but you know as had a planetary and we
were putting this together
i said we absolutely have to have a
phone call sorry i'm sorry i took a
guess
say it again jim i i stepped up boulders
i went with cup holders but i'm sorry
say it again but what is it
okay so the new instrument that's on it
that i
i really like is a microphone
this allows us to hear
the sounds of mars sweet yeah now i
i don't expect it at night while tree
well uh perseverance is sitting there
grunging away with stuff that we hear
the crickets
but we're going to hear all kinds of
sounds as the rover moves
it you know we can use it from an
engineering perspective because if you
hear metal against metal we're going to
stop
it right away and figure out what's
happening and so um
not only is it going to be fantastic to
listen to the winds and the sound of
mars
will actually hear the sounds of the
rover moving
during the day and even at night but the
first thing in the world would be
is if you heard this are they gone yet
yeah you're right right right or or or
quick duck the camera's turning this way
get out of the way
[Laughter]
i would dearly like that let's see if we
can find that in the data
the weird thing is not that you would
hear them speaking but that they'd be
speaking english that would be the total
weird thing
exactly james we got to call it quits
there listen
uh good luck to you and the mission and
all you we and
it's not the parent here in this
interview but thousands of people work
on these
on these crafts they do all right
excellent james i will get back to you
when
when it arrives at mars safely uh we'll
get you back on and just get an update
on how this is turning out my pleasure
let's do it chuck
always good to see you man always a
pleasure to be here all right this has
been a special edition
star talk explainer getting the latest
on our missions to mars as always keep
looking up
especially if you're looking at mars
you